Я втратив країну, роботу, газету, родину, дім -
буквально усе. Це був найгірший рік у моєму житті.
Джан Дюндар вже рік живе у Берліні,
однак дуже сумує за батьківщиною.
У Туреччині він був головним редактором газети Cumhuriyet.
Через критичні матеріали президент Ердоган особисто подав проти нього позов.
Журналіста брали під варту, доправляли до суду,
ому коли з’явилася можливість, він виїхав до Німеччини.
В якомусь сенсі я привіз тюремну камеру із собою до Німеччини.
Адже тут я живу як у в’язниці -
з міркувань безпеки не надто часто виходжу на вулицю,
здебільшого зосереджуюсь на боротьбі
та намагаюся підтримати своїх друзів у в’язниці.
За судовим процесом, який розпочався в Стамбулі,
Дюндар стежить зі свого берлінського офісу.
Серед обвинувачених - він сам та багато інших співробітників видання.
Більшість з них - близькі друзі Дюндара.
Aкін - видавець і водночас мій адвокат.
Він приходив до мене у в’язницю, витяг мене звідти, але тепер опинився там сам.
КадрІ ГюрсЕл - один з найвідоміших авторів у Туреччині -
я запросив його до Cumhuriyet, він погодився і лише кілька місяців потому його арештували.
Учасники демонстрації на захист журналістів
називають цей судовий процес фарсом.
Тим часом обвинувачення закидає газеті
підтримку терористичних організацій.
Такої ж думки і президент Ердоган,
він запевняє - жоден журналіст, якщо це дійсно журналіст,
не може бути за ґратами в його країні.
Ми отримали список, у якому 149 начебто ув’язнених журналістів.
Ми перевірили його: 144 з них
у в’язниці через підозри у тероризмі,
ешта – звичайні злочинці.
Це така позиція влади - у кожному опоненті уряду вони вбачають терориста.
Тому якщо ви зробили твіт, написали статтю або новину,
яка їм не сподобалася, ви тут же стаєте для них терористом.
Саме тому Ердоган каже, що вони не  журналісти, а терористи.
Джан Дюндар і надалі намагається писати критичні матеріали з Берліна
спільно з німецькими журналістами.
Та не втрачає надії, що його колеги у Туреччині
скоро зможуть знову вільно працювати.
Звичайно, я сподіваюся на краще майбутнє,
тому що ситуація погіршується з кожним днем.
Я не думаю, що люди довго зможуть терпіти цю агресивну владу.
Тому покладаю великі сподіваюся на майбутнє -
просто ми готуємося до нього тут.